Yeah, well, and actually the the the root, one of the main meanings of that root is guiding teacher.
Which is what we so desperately need at this time.
Okay, can you guys uh join my screen again? I'm sorry.
Yeah, we can do that.
Brother.
All right, I'm here.
Okay, can can you tell me who else is here? Is Mona here?
Yes.
I'm here.
Okay, can you see my screen? And Fatima?
Yes, Fatima.
Yes, I can.
Okay, okay. So, uh where we left off is is is, you know, the root word of Rashad is in between this context.
And in here, this believing Egyptian comes out of nowhere and just says, "Hey, how can you kill a man for doing this, right?" Now, here is the first mention of the word of of Rashad. It's in verse 40:29, right? Rashad, right? Here is the second mention of the word Rashad. It's in verse 40:38, Rashad, right? Remember, these are the only two mentions, the only two mentions of of Rashad in the entire Quran, right? And right dead set in the middle, right dead set in the middle, right? It says, "Joseph has come to you before that with clear revelations, but you continue to doubt his message. Then when he died, you said, 'God will not send any other messenger after him.' He was the last messenger. God thus sends astray those who are transgressors, doubtful."
Now, isn't it very interesting that in between the only two mentions of of Rashad in the entire Quran, right dead set in the middle, is God warning you against making that, you know, against people saying, "Hey, the previous messenger was the last messenger." And and also look at this. What was God's response to people saying the previous messenger was the last messenger? God's response was a bad one, right? God says, "I, so God thus sends astray those who are transgressors, doubtful."
So, God is already warning you against making this claim that the previous messenger was the last messenger. His response was, He sends you astray. And then God goes on further. They argue against God's revelations without any basis. This is a trait that is most abhorred by God and by those who believe. God thus seals the heart of every arrogant talent, tyrant. Ready? So, look, what was God's response to people thinking the previous messenger was the last messenger? Did God respond in a positive way? What did He say? He said, "He abhors this." He said, "I I this is how I send people astray. I abhor this. He hates this, right?" And it's between the only two mentions of Rashad in the entire Quran, right? Al-Rashad and then Al-Rashad, uh in verse 40:38, right? And I also wanted to add, uh uh, you know, another very interesting thing here. You know, this one who believed is the believing Egyptian that came up in verse 40:28 here. So, he's believing, he's a believing Egyptian. And by the way, Rashad was Egyptian. But this believing Egyptian comes out of nowhere, right? And he says, "Oh, my people, follow me and I will guide you in the right way, in the way and and the right way is Rashad, right?"
So, who is this believing Egyptian who is not a messenger, but he's acting like a messenger? You know what I mean? He's speaking with this authority. Like, who in the Quran says, "Follow me and I will guide you in the right way." Who is this believing believing Egyptian that comes out of nowhere and starts telling people to follow him, right? It's almost like he's mirroring Rashad. And it's in between the only two mentions of Al-Rashad, right? In the entire Quran, right? Uh so, it's in between the only two mentions of the entire of Al-Rashad in the entire Quran. And right dead set in the middle, it's it's, you know, God warning you against thinking the previous messenger was the last messenger, right?
Now, there is another interesting one. It's it's in it's in verse uh it's in chapter 72.
Mr. McLincan.
Yeah, what's up?
Uh the the verse where you're saying that it's sort of mirroring Rashad, is uh is does that happen to be a multiple of 19?
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, it's it's uh 19 times 2, by the way.
Oh, very interesting. All right, that's.
Okay, so I I wanted to go on to Surah Jinn. Now, what's interesting is in this Surah, Rashad cited a lot of mathematical things in here, right? But if we just scroll all the way down, we see some very interesting associations here, right? Right? So, you know, um God says that He is the knower of the future and He does not reveal the future to anyone, all right? Except to a messenger that He chooses, does He reveal from the past and the future specific news, right? This is to ascertain that they have delivered their Lord's messengers. He is fully aware of what they have. He has counted the numbers of all things.
So, are you seeing what I'm seeing here, right? So, he's talking about messengers. He's he's he's talking about giving messengers specific things, right? And then he's associating that with counting the numbers of all things and He knows what the messengers have. So, He counted the numbers of what the messengers have, right? And interestingly, that phrase, "Only to a messenger that He chooses," has a gematrical value of 1919, right? And then if we even go on further, do you see this word here?
It says, "Khalfihi Rasada." Khalfihi Rasada. So, hold on. Does that sound like Khalifa Rashad here? Now, obviously, it's not the same word, but it has an interesting sound to it. It sounds exactly the same. So, hold on. So, this verse here is saying that God uh gives messengers specific things and God has counted the numbers of all the things and God knows all the numbers of the things that the messengers have. And it it even and the only two messengers that He chooses has a gematrical value of 1919. And he uses the word Khalfihi Rasada all in the same context. Right? It's very interesting. It's very interesting that all of this is in the same context. Again, only to a messenger that He chooses has a gematrical value of 1919. God talks about messengers getting things in the context of numbers and God has counted the numbers of all things including the things that the messengers have. And he uses the word Khalfihi Rasada. Very interesting, right? And and if if you add these up, 7 + 2 + 2 + 8, it's also uh adds up to 19.
But let's also go up to here, right? Because this is a uh you know, this is actually a nice mirror to what happened uh with Rashad, basically, right? So, it says, "The places of worship belong to God. Do not call upon anyone else beside God." When God's servant advocated Him alone, almost all of them banded together to oppose him. Right? Now, if if you know anything about Rashad, what basically he said is he said, "You can't add Muhammad to your Shahada. You can't add Muhammad to your prayers. You can't do any of that, right?" So, when he did that, right? Almost all of them banded together to oppose him, right? And and he says, "Look, you can't put Muhammad's name next to God in the mosque, right?" It says, "The places of worship belong to God. Don't call anyone else." But they they even have a thing called, where they're like, "As-salamu alayka, ya ayyuhan-nabiyyu," and all that stuff, right? So, and so, it's basically saying, "Hey, all all of this this message that that he's saying, he's just advocating the worship of God alone. And almost all of them banded together to oppose him, right?" And and do you want to know what's interesting about this? It's verse 19 of all verses.
Not only that, but 72 + 19 is also 19.
Yeah, like 7 + 2.
It's prodigious.
Yeah.
Wait, wait, wait, wait. 72 + 19?
7 + 2 + 1 + 9.
Wait, wait, wait. I never even Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa. It's verse 19 and then you add the digits, it's also 19. Dang, you won up me, Mr. McLincan. Praise God. I've never known that in 20 years of submission.
Well, well, so what's interesting is that Mr. McLincan is pointing to these to these these these two verses, 72:19 to 72:20 to 72:28. And both 72:19 and 72:28, their digits add up to 19. It's like showcasing the cutout that this is relevant to the code 19. This is between these two points.
And guys, the phrase, "Only to a messenger that He chooses," has a gematrical value of 1919. Rashad worded it right. Where did he where did he say it? It's right here somewhere. Yeah, here it is. "Only to a messenger that He chooses," has a value of 1919. There is so much in this in just these two chapters and believe me, we're not even close to being done yet. There's so much in these two chapters here that are are are like giving you giant red flags and giant hints, right? That, "Hey, this guy here, he's a messenger." He they even use a word that sounds just like his name in the context of God counting the number of the things the messengers have and a phrase that has a gematrical value of 1919 all in the same context. And then it talks about the main uh the main message of of basically of of Rashad, right? And and it's verse 19. If you add the digits, it's a multiple of 19. And it's basically just Rashad preaching strict monotheism, right? What kind of um like if if you think about a messenger from God, like what kind of message could be possibly more pure than, "Hey, I want your entire religion focused on God and nobody else," right? I mean, it's just the central message. But, hold on, there's a lot more to it, right?
So, he said that the root word of Rashad exists, you know, in the Quran 19 times, right?
Sorry.
Yeah, please go ahead.
I'm going to interrupt. Is this being recorded? Because it should be.
Yes, it actually is. It actually is.
Brilliant. Okay, thank you.
Oh, very good.
Okay, so, um what I was going to say is that the the the, you know, we know the root of Rashad, right? Is is in the Quran 19 times, right? Um and and Mona, I wanted to ask you this, guess how many years he was a messenger?
19.
Oh, yeah. And and ready? Check this out. Ready? So, he was a messenger and he's he started being a messenger in 1971, right? And and and here it is again talking about how, you know, this is the day he became a messenger, right? And we know he died on uh 1990, right?
Right? So, that's 19 years. So, Rashad was a messenger for 19 years. Now, the Quran says that God is the one who who controls life and death, right? So, how would Rashad know when he was going to die? Because he he wrote when he was like, he wrote when he was going to be a messenger before he died, obviously, right? So, how did Rashad know when he was going to die, right? It's interesting that he was a messenger for 19 years. The root of his name is, you know, in the Quran 19 years, right? But, hold on, let's just go a little further, right?
Okay, so, do you see here that this is Rashad's birthday, right? November 19, 1935. And he died in January 31st, 1990, right? Okay, so, I have an interesting um uh so, so, it's it's just an app that calculates the number of days between the two dates. So, I put November 19, 1935, and you can go ahead and verify it here. And then I have uh uh January 31st, 1990. You can go ahead and verify it here, right? And the number of days between these two dates is 19,798. Okay, now, uh just very briefly, let's just see if this is a multiple of 19 or not.
Oh, it turns out to be a multiple of 19. Very interesting, right? Now, there's more to this number than you realize. Um, do you know about code 19 in general, like the uh mysterious initials?
Mona?
Yeah, I do. It has 29 chapters.
Yeah, yeah, right, right. So, do you know which chapter has the most of those mysterious initials? And take a guess, it's probably the the right amount. Like, it's probably the right number. It's yeah, it's chapter 19. So, chapter 19 has the most initials, right? In the entire Quran. Chapter 19 has the most initials, right? So, um here's chapter 19, right? So, so, so, all the other chapters have like the one that has the second most is Taha Sin Mim and Alif Lam Mim Sad and Alif Lam Mim Ra, right? But chapter 19 has five of them, right? Uh uh, you know, Kaf, Ha, Ya, Ain, Sad, right? Five. 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, right?
Are you guys still with me?
Yes.
Yes, we are.
Okay, so, chapter so, in code 19, chapter 19 has the most initials, right? And if we count the initials and and and this is actually from uh from our user, Dude, who actually color-coded and counted the initials of this chapter. And by the way, this is not contested, right? Uh basically, everybody agrees with this, right? So, let's count the number of uh of initials in this chapter. All right, so, it's 798. Okay, I'm going to repeat, it's chapter 19 has the most initials in the Quran. And it has 798. Do you see what's going on here?
Are you guys seeing it? 19.
798.
And then chapter.
Can you be specific?
Okay, so.
Days, that's days, Mona, days.
The number of days that Rashad lived is 19,798.
19,798.
Right? And the number of initials in chapter 19 is 798. 19.
Chapter 19, yeah.
Mute yourself, please.
Okay, so, chapter 19 has 798, right? And Rashad lived 19,798.
Very cool.
I understand.
Mona, did did you understand it?
Yes, I did. Thank you.
Okay, so, we know that God controls life and death, right? So, not only is the the number of days he lived a multiple of 19, but it's also the uh like it's also the number of initials of the chapter with the most initials in the Quran, which has uh 7 uh 798 uh counts of those initials, right? Isn't that very interesting? And another uh uh okay, so, how are we so far? Do you kind of understand uh what's being said so far?
Yep, I do.
Okay, so, um let's see, um where else was I going to go to? Oh, okay, so, um do you know where his mosque is?
Tucson.
More specifically, this is his address, uh 739 East 6th Street, right? Um let's add up the uh the initials like the the the the address number.
19. Okay? Interesting, right? Hey, uh it's also in uh Tucson, Arizona. Hey, please, can can can we please uh uh it's also in in Tucson, Arizona. And what does that zip code end in? Do you guys see it?
19.
19. Okay, let's take a look at the map. So, here's the map, right? Here is Messenger Tucson. Okay, do you see uh which highway it is off of?
No.
19.
It's off of Highway 19 and it's also off of Highway 10. We'll talk about Highway 10 in just a second. But do you see which highway it is off of? So, the digits add up to 19. The zip code.
That's the only.
The zip code.
Navid, stop. I know. Navid, stop, stop, stop.
God is running it.
The zip code ends in 19, right? And this is the only Highway 19 in the entire US. Right? Now, what's interesting is this highway was built after Rashad moved to Tucson. Do you guys hear what I said? This highway was not yet built, right? When he moved to Tucson. It was built after he moved to Tucson, Arizona. Right? So, the zip code is a multiple of 19. The digits add up to 19. And it's off of the only Highway 19 in the entirety of the US. There's so many 19s around here. Now, what's the significance of this Highway 10 here as well? If if you guys remember, there are 29 uh uh uh chapters in the Quran that have those code 19 initials, which is 19 + 10, 29, right? Another thing, Rashad was martyred. He was he was stabbed 29 times. Almost like the almost like it was pointing out to to that event. Like 10 + 19 is 29, right? So, it's very, very interesting, right? That all these 19s are are are, you know, coming up all and it kind of intersecting at where Rashad is, right? So, not only did we get what we got from the Quran, right? But we got all of these signs, right?
Now, how about this? Verse 19:19, right? Would you think there's anything significant about that verse in the Quran? Right? Because what's interesting is, if you look at the gematrical value of verse 19:19, it has a gematrical value of uh uh of 1990. And it has 31 letters. And it just so happens, as we as we talked about, that Rashad died on the 31st day of 1990. So, chapter 19 of the Quran has a lot of these things that is related to Rashad's life and death. And if you remember, God says in the Quran that God controls life and death, that nobody dies except by God's leave at a predetermined time. So, we know that God did this, that God allowed these initials in in chapter 19 to have, you know, to have to have 798 and to have Rashad live, you know, 19,798. So, 19798, right? So, we see that God is the one that did that, right? And not only that, we have the root of Rashad's name being in the Quran exactly 19 times. And the only, again, repeat, the only two mentions of the actual full name Rashad is in between a very significant context, right? Where dead set in the middle, God is rebuking people. He's warning people against thinking the previous messenger was the last messenger. Right? So, he's he's he's rebuking them. He's saying, "I hate this. Don't do this. This is a trait that is most abhorred by God, right? God and and then it even warns you, God seals the heart of of of those people, right?" So, this is a trait that is hated by God, right? To to to think the previous messenger was the last messenger, right? And it's right in the middle. It's right in the middle of the only two mentions of Rashad in the entire Quran, right? And all in the same context, it's a believing Egyptian talking about uh, you know, killing a man just for saying, "My Lord is God," and has and has shown you clear proofs. And he he comes out of nowhere as if mirroring Rashad, right? As if saying, "Follow me," like as if he's a messenger, "and I will guide you in the right way." And then we have Surah 72.
Can I interrupt?
Yeah, please go ahead.
McLincan, when you say it's right in the middle, can you specify whether there's any other verses that separate them or are we talking exact? I'm entertaining that.
There's four verses here. So, here ready? Here's verse 40:34, right? So, ready? 1, 2, 3, 4. This is the second mention of Rashad, right? So, here's here's verse 40:34. 1, 2, 3, 4. Or maybe I'm missing this out here. 40:29, 1, 2, 3, 4. So, there's four verses between, right? How did he say this? How did he say this? Uh the Jews refused to believe the Messiah and then. Okay, it is nowhere that we find the name Rashad four verses ahead of the injunction of saying the last messenger. And also four verses ahead of it. 1, 2, 3, 4. Okay, 1, 2, 3, 4. I I I guess this one's here, Al-Rashad here. But regardless, the only two mentions of Rashad in the entire Quran, right? The only two mentions in the entire Quran, right? Is in between this context here where God says that the uh, you know, He hates people who think the previous messenger was the last messenger, right? Do you understand the significance here?
So, there's four verses and the fifth one is the one that we're talking about. Is that how that's in the middle?
No, no. So, all all you so, the only thing that really matters here is the only two mentions of Rashad in the entire Quran is in between this context, right? You know what I mean? It's in between this context and it's in between a place where it says God uh uh, you know, uh God hates it when when people think the previous messenger is the last messenger. It's in between that very significant context. Do you kind of get what we're saying?
Okay.
So, hold on, again, the only two mentions of Rashad is in this very significant context.
Yeah, back to the mosque. Apparently, it might have been built 1919, I'd read as well.
Yeah, yeah, how did you Yeah, I know that can be verified.
Yeah, how did you know? Yeah, yeah, it was. Hold on.
I've been doing some digging.
I'm I'm I'm going to try to find the article that talks about it, but yeah, as as far as I know, it was also built in 1919, yeah.
Really? I did not know that.
Do we have the exact day or year that the highway was built out of curiosity or completed, rather?
Yeah, yeah, hold on. Uh just give me one second. Let me just do take this one at a time. Well, you know, at least according to this news article, it was built in 1919 by Henry Jastad. Very interesting. Um yeah, so, uh I actually have this here somewhere. Give me one second. About the highway being built. It's going to be under math miracle. I talked about it before. Let me see here. Okay, so, we see here that Rashad moved to the United States in 1959, right? To get a master's degree in in Tucson, right? Um what's interesting is uh this highway, Interstate 19, which is the only Interstate 19, was built uh hold on. Okay, here it is. It was built in 1962. Do you see that? And and by the way, Rashad discovered code 19 in 1974. So, this was even before he knew anything about 19, by the way, as well. So, he moved there in 1950 something. What was it? 1959. And the highway was built like five years later, right? And and he and he didn't even discover code 19 until 1974.
Wow.
Mona, did that answer your question?
Yeah, it does. Thank you.
All right, uh Fatima, uh Fatima and and and everybody else, uh what do you guys want to say about this?
Fatima, you go first.
I'm I'm absorbing it all. Um Subhanallah, like just seeing all of it, um especially the verses that and that you started off with, that was amazing, honestly. I'm I'm still pretty speechless. It's going to take me a little bit to digest, but thank you for the thorough thorough um walk through of all of this.
Yeah, praise God. And you know, it's interesting that the only.
No.
No, no. Well, yeah, technically, yeah, I guess.
Wait, hold on. So, do we make clear that uh his birthday, I I believe it's the only year that is the 19th and then it's also a multiple of 19 or one of the only? I forgot what that was.
No, uh Sam said it here, November 19 is the only day of the year that's also a multiple of 19.
Wait, what? So, like if if you count the only 19 like January 19, February 19 and all of that, November 19 is the 323rd day. So, it's the only day that is a that is a 19th of a month that's also a multiple of 19.
What's chapter what's chapter 19:17 out of interest?
19 what?
What's chapter 19:17 out of interest?
No, no, 19:19 of all of all verses.
19:19.
Yeah, it has a gematrical value of 1990 and it has 31 letters and that that's also the day that Rashad left.
Yeah, yeah.
You know, like I understand that, but the 19:17, if what's that chapter and verse?
Where are you getting 19:17 from?
Where is 17 coming from?
19 times 17 at the bottom. The 323rd day.
Oh, no, no, that's just the uh no, no, that's just a multiple of 19. So, ready?
Can you visit chapter 19 verse 17?
No, no, no, no, no. It's just saying that 323 is a multiple of 19. That's all it's saying.
It's just 323 is one a multiple of 19 while also being the only day of that year that is also the 19th of that month.
McLincan, she just McLincan, she just wants to read the verse what it says.
It's in the chat. It's in the chat.
I'll put it in the chat.
I'll put it in the chat. Uh now, I did want to mention like the uh like all the all the hints in the Quran, it's it's startling because you either have to say that God is trying to guide you through all those through those hints or the second option is that we're not supposed to be guided by that at all. Or the third option is that Satan is using a lot of hints from the Quran to mislead us. Those are the two options.
But but Triple A, but hold on, it can't be Satan because Satan did not author the Quran. We know God did this. So, this is what God put in His own Quran, right? Number two, God controls, hold on, let me just let me just answer them. I I know that you know their positions, but like number two, God controls life and death. So, the number of days Rashad lived and the and the and the initial count and the only chapter 19 and the one with the most initials, right? All of that is what God did, right? And and the most important thing here is what kind of Satan is is his whole purpose is to make you put God the center of your life and worship God alone and call don't call on anybody except God and dedicate your entire life to God and seek God's kingship over you alone, right? What kind of Satan would do that? What kind of stupid Satan would do that? Right?
So, so, would God be intentionally misleading us or is He intentionally trying to guide us through all these hints?
Hold on. Is there any precedent in the Quran of God giving people signs and people are not supposed to follow those signs?
I don't think so.
Yeah, there's not. Anytime God gives a sign and a messenger and that messenger is preaching God alone, all all the time in the Quran, the requirement is to worship God alone and follow that messenger, right? Always. There's no exception to that.
Alhamdulillah.
Can you repeat again that last bit you mentioned about why it can't be Satan?
Yes, so, um uh it's God's Quran that has these miracles, right? So, Satan did not author the Quran, unless you believe he authored the Quran, but he did not. In our belief, he did not author the Quran, right? Uh uh, so, that's number one, right? Uh the uh second thing is God controls life and death and the the amount of days Rashad lived and its correlation with the Quran, it's it's only from God, right? And the third thing is anybody who tells you, "Hey, come worship God alone, dedicate your entire life to God, remember God all the time." In fact, your God is whatever occupies your mind the most. You have to make sure God occupies your mind the most and to seek God's kingship over you. A person who is so devoted and focused on God with no with no partners, right? And and who's so against Satan, right? That message by itself is clearly a beautiful, it's clearly the right message. It's not a message that Satan would want you to follow, right?
So, wait, uh Mr. McLincan, I believe you did answer Mona, but I I think there was um the part that she she really wants to hone in on was uh the idea that uh so, she wants to make sure that this is not Satan misguiding us. And the thing is the point that you you you made that that you inserted within all your words was that he since he decrees time and the the life the the point where you live and die, that means Satan did not determine when Rashad died. That means God had intentionally had him had had him die at that time. And that would confirm the 798 count of uh Surah 19. So, if you're going to if you're going to try to claim that all these signs are Satan's mechanisms, well, God had to work with Satan on that point. Right? You like, basically, since God is the one who determines when Rashad dies, making him die at that specific moment to make us see the 1978 correlation, if you're going to claim that all the other hints are from Satan, this one specifically had to come from God. And so, if you're going to claim that all the other messengers are Satan misleading us, then God had to work on the had to work with the devil on the the the the death date of Rashad to make it go along with Satan.
And guys, uh and I I also want to emphasize because I, you know, like this here is actually bigger than you think. Again, it talks about God giving things to messengers in the context of numbers. He counted the numbers of all the things that the messengers have. Think about it, guys, the the numbers. What is Rashad's entire thing? It's all about numbers and code 19. It's God is connecting messengers getting things to to him counting the numbers of the things they have, right? And the and the gematrical value of only to a messenger that He chooses is 1919. And God counted that too because God says He counted the numbers of all things. So, God knows the gematrical value of only to a messenger that He chooses is 1919. And then there's also Khalfihi Rasada all in the same context. All in the same context. It has it's basically Rashad, numbers, messenger. Again, Rashad, numbers, messenger. All in the same context, right? And then it's not only it's it's it's not just Rashad, it's Khalifa Rashad. Rashad Khalifa, messengers, numbers, right? And then uh if you add, you know, 7 + 2 + 2 + 8 is 19. And if you go to to verse 19, it's basically talking about like the like what did Rashad really teach? The the whole point was, "Hey, I don't uh, you know, these traditional Muslims, they they they they want to add somebody else, right? But all Rashad taught, 'Hey, stop that. I just want you to worship God alone and call on Him alone and don't and and don't like add anybody else, right?' The focus of the entire religion is to God, right? The places of worship belong to God. Don't call anybody else. And then when God's servant advocated Him alone, almost all of them banded together to oppose him." And look at that, it's verse 19. And and then it even adds up to 19. It's just there's so much in this one context, you know what I mean?
Question.
Um Yeah.
Those last three verses, 26, 27, 28, you're mentioning, right? With the correlation and whatnot.
Yeah.
Uh how are they being understood or interpreted by mainstream traditionalism?
I don't have an understanding of that.
I think uh as as like as as far as I've been reading about what they say, they they basically just say like like like, you know, what you're reading here is that, you know, God knows the future. He he does reveal the future to anybody. I mean, if you if you read any other translation, it's basically the same thing. All we're seeing, though, is we're seeing uh you know, God counting the number of things the messengers have, right? And and and and and we see a word that sounds like Khalfihi Rasada. And and and and the connection with messengers, right?
So, how would they interpret the number of all things? I mean, other than obvious biology and pairs and whatnot. That could be the reference, right? In the nature um and evolution of all things. But it would seem kind of out of context unless they can string together a logical argument like the one you've been able to do to support this.
I'm not sure I understand the question. Would anybody else like to answer that?
Wait, so, are you asking how did how did other translators interpret this verse where God keeps the count of all things?
Yes.
We don't know about them even doing that. We don't know. So, I'm looking it up right now to see how other translators translate this verse. I'll put it in the chat. But basically, they're saying uh I'm in the wrong Surah. They're basically saying uh that first off, the statement that God keeps track of all things, no one's going to deny that just because we already know God is omniscient. Of course, He keeps track of all things, right? But the the fact that God mentions it in such a way at this point in time is significant. And here, here, I I here's the I found it. Uh and I'm going to put their their other interpretation there. So, that it's not just Rashad's. Here, here's like four different interpretations. And he keeps the count of everything. He takes account of everything. He keepeth count of all things. He takes account of every single thing. And then if you look up there, you see that He takes account of all things in number. Like, the word number is right there. I I did. I did. I did. I don't know how to read that. I did. But it's it's number, right? So, the he he makes a specific mention of number here. And this is the same verse where you have the digits.
Hey, Mona, yeah, so, if you can see my screen, the Arabic here says, which means number in Arabic.
I understand that. I'm just curious, you guys have been able to paint a very coherent, systematic approach to how these three verses all correlate. What's the counter argument to that in the traditional realm? That's all.
Well, if you like consider the traditional people existed long before Rashad did, right? So, they're not going to say anything specific about it. They're just going to say what the verse says, that God knows the number of everything. Like, there's no um uh like I think you're thinking that, "Hey, what do they say about this with regards to Rashad?" I'm not even sure if they know about this.
In the greater context of the theme of the chapter, though, and the Surah and the verse that supersedes it and and follows it, though. Can we take a look at that real quick?
Um.
So, just look at.
Yeah, Triple A, can you take a look at that? I'm I'm not really sure what.
All right, so, I'm going to just go through it uh by mouth. Say, no one can protect me from God, nor can I find any. So, there's a little bit of uh.
Oh, you want to see the Tafsir of this Surah?
I mean, I'm not really sure what like what the relevance is of what those people think, but let's see, where's Surah Jinn?
72, I think. So, it would be.
Yeah, it's not numbered. Oh, here it is. Okay. So, let's see what uh Ibn Kathir, which is one of the more popular ones, said about it. Okay. So, verily, Allah knows those who believe and He knows the hypocrites. It should be added that these examples that from Allah's knowledge is that He knows all things before they occur. And this is something definite and certain. Therefore, He says after this, uh and He surrounds all of that which is with them and He keeps count of all things. This is the end of Surah Al-Jinn. All praise and thanks due to God. So, like this is what we'd expect. They just repeat the claim that God knows the count of all things, right?
They don't read it, they don't read into it, this this Mona. And I honestly, I don't think they really had to read into it until this point in time. That's that's the thing. Because um Muhammad is the one who's was the one who delivered the Quran. There's no reason to keep track of all the things surrounding Muhammad at that time. Because they've they've this is the this is the miracle at that time. Now, who want to prove that the next messenger after him is a a true messenger, can we showcase how God kept track of all the things around Rashad or whoever that is coming messenger ship? Because here in this verse, it's indicating that around the messengers, God keeps count of all things. Right? And only in this day of the information age can we actually see this through our own eyes because we we actually also have been keeping track of all things regarding people, right?
Brilliant. Yep, no, I'm following perfectly and that that really helped. Thank you.
And and it's um you you I think you just Mona, just take the hints, right? It says, "God counted the number of all things and only to a messenger He chooses has a gematrical value of 1919, right?" And and then it talks about messengers. It talks about numbers. And and it talks and it has a gematrical value of 1919. And it uses the word Khalfihi Rasada all in the same context. Like, take the hint, you know?
We just can we note a couple of additional things about this chapter? So, chapter 72 contains the most instances of Rashad or Rashada in it of all the chapters. It has four. We said there's 19 total in the entire Quran. This chapter alone contains four instances. This is the chapter that Rashad talks about being in reference to Masjid Tucson. And also, this is the chapter where verse 19 talks about God's advocate, I'm sorry, God's servant advocating him alone and almost everyone banding together to oppose him.
And it's verse 19, guys, by the way, it's verse 19, by the way.
It's verse 19, right? And now, what's interesting is also verse 18, it says, "The places of worship belong to God. Do not call on anyone else beside God." Isn't it interesting at the time, the only masjid on Earth that's devoted to God alone is Masjid Tucson. And Rashad is claiming that this this Surah is talking about Masjid Tucson. Now, what's also interesting is um uh from the beginning of the Quran until this verse, 27, which uh references what the messenger that's chosen, the number of verses, it's um 5,472. Get this, which is 19, get this, times 72, which is the chapter number, times 4, which is the four times that Rashad is mentioned. Not only is it a multiple of 19.
Yeah, what's that?
You might want to type that out to visualize for.
I did. I did. I did. I put it in the chat.
I'm not.
It's there in the ball. So, Rashada occurs in this chapter four times. This is chapter 72. Number of the verses from the beginning of the Quran all the way to this um verse is 5,472, which is 19, it's a multiple of 19. It's 19 times 72, chapter number, times 4, which is the number of times Rashada occurs. Additionally, if you take Rashada and you add the verse numbers, you get uh what is it? 532, which is 19 times 28, which is also the number of verses there here. But also, if you just take um again, just take Rashad Khalifa, chapter number, verse number, you get another multiple of 19. And of course, we already said the digits are they add up to 19. And the value of the expression, "Only to a messenger that He chooses," has a value of 1919. So, that's very compelling, but may I add something else that's quite interesting? All of this is coming out of a chapter titled Al-Jinn. Why with Allah's infinite mercy and wisdom, would He not include it as chapter 74, which is the one about the hidden secret, hypothetically?
So, Mona, chapter Jinn is not the one that convinced me that he was a messenger. It was actually chapter 40, by the way.
Yeah, I think you missed it. Most of this was from 40, which is forgiver. All the Egyptian debate thing was from uh 40.
If I could say something just really quick. I mean, I feel like it's a good uh good summary of events, but what I think is fascinating is how is it possible this one guy pieced this stuff together, right? How many people have been conditioned to believe that the end of the world is absolutely hidden, even though the word almost is in the verse, right? That they were deliberately blind from being able to see something so obvious. It's like this isn't uh again, it's funny when it's pointed out, like, "Dude, how did no one else notice this?" It's it's bizarre.
Yeah, no, I I I completely agree. I I just I don't really know.
Peter, I think the discovery is that there are many occurrences like that as well. That's not the only one. Unfortunately.
Yeah.
Can you expand on that? What do you mean?
She she I think she's referring to the fact that she's noticed other other verses have also been misinterpreted for the last thousand years or so as well, right? Mona, that's what you meant?
Yeah, that's correct. That's correct.
Yeah, like uh versus about Solomon with the horses and the the the has thrown.
How is it possible this one guy, right? He's not some like eminent scholar, something. He's a biochemist by trade. And he's just studying the Quran and he's able to uncover all these facts. Like the the simplest one is just the Shahada. But you do not find a single scholar, anyone saying that, "Hey, guys, why are you saying the Shahada to him?" Right? It's like these stuff that are so blatantly obvious. It's almost comical when it's once it's revealed.
And and and look, verse 19 of that chapter is talking about the main thing Rashad did. Ready? The places of worship belong to God. Don't call anybody else. When God's servant advocated him alone, almost all of them banded together to oppose him. It's it's literally talking about like the like the central message of what Rashad was was teaching. And it's verse 19 of all verses.
But this is not the only one. So, we actually have multiple verse 19s that prophesies Rashad. And every time you add his name to the Surah and verse number, it's a multiple of 19. 5:19 is one, 81:19 is one, what? 70 uh I'm sorry, what is it? Um shoot. 81:19, 5:19, both of those, you add his name, Rashad Khalifa, and the verse Surah number, you get a multiple of 19. Exact same methodology. And both of them are talking about a messenger that comes. Um the other two. Yeah, I wanted to read a verse, 24:54, guys. It says, "Say, obey God and obey the messenger. If they refuse, then he is responsible for his obligations and you're responsible for your obligations. If you obey him, you will be guided. The sole duty of the messenger is to deliver the message." There was another one that talks about or I guess we already read that from chapter 40. Is there another one that says something like that where it's like, you know, if he's wrong or whatever, you know, you don't lose anything or something like that.
Well, I mean, stop the again, the the the believing man who's talking to Pharaoh, you lose nothing by by uh listening to him. And if he's telling the truth, you only benefit, right? So, I I I think that's that's indicating that even if he ends up not being a messenger, if his if what he's preaching is truth, then there's nothing to worry about.
Well, this is my this is my whole thing is if he's the only religious like person on the planet in terms of like some kind of like capacity to exert his opinion, he's saying, "God is Allah." Or at least the first one to to do that. Isn't that already a very positive sign and proof of his messenger ship?
No, not only that, like he did not even want to claim messenger ship because he thought that was not important. He didn't want to draw eyes on him. He wanted people to just see the right message and to follow it and he didn't care for the credits, right? If he was hiding it for eight years, this showcases what his intentions are. When he was forced to give announce his messenger ship, he realized the the flaw in his theory, right? He's like, "All right, it looks like, you know, being reasonable is not all that is not sufficient. I need I need to, you know, uh take my place as what God has appointed me to do," right? Right, exactly. And and but but but he but he resisted that for eight years, right? He's like, "Look, I'm just going to go to people, say, 'God alone, Quran alone.' Look, reject Hadith. That's it. Just reject Hadith. God alone, Quran alone." You know, just similar concept to all these Quranists today. But why do we need a messenger? We can all just read the Quran. And it's like, "No, you need that authority. You need a definitive answer on these key issues. There's no way around it. Otherwise, you're not going to have a religion." And this is why I promise you, there is never going to be a a Quranist, I guess the only way a Quranist uh uh masjid can be formed is if they they claim some messenger and they fall in line because of some messenger. But just free free styling, free form Quranism cannot have any congregation. It's not possible.
No, yeah.
So, but Hey, and uh and uh Triple A, this one's for you. It's it's more complicated, but I think it's important. I you know, I I deliberately overlooked it because it's just going to complicate things. But the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa is 1230. Uh you're aware of that, right?
Uh uh, I am, but pause for a second because your your screen's not showing up. Let me leave and come back, all right?
Oh, okay, okay. Yeah.
Yeah, so, so, yeah, yeah. Before you continue, so, we already talked about the number of days he lived was 19,798, which is a multiple of 19. And chapter 19 has 798 uh letter initials. And also has the most initials and it's in chapter 19 of all chapters with the most initials of five. 798. And Rashad lived 19798, just like chapter 19. Very impressive, you know? And then and then we go to 1919, right? We go to 1919 and what is it? The the what is it? The gematrical value or or yeah, hold on. Yeah, the gematrical value is 1990 and the number of letters is 31. And he was he he was martyred on January 31st, 1990. But separate from that, let's just write the date of death, date of death, right? We got 31, hold on, it's blurry. You do that, it becomes blurry. Just remove that. Yeah. 31011990. That's 19 times 1230 times 1327. And 1230 is the uh initial verse is 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one.
The last one.
So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And the 1327th initial verse is the last verse of chapter 19. So, there's a lot hold on. It's code 19. Chapter 19 has the most initials of all of them. It has the number of initials corresponding to the number of days Rashad lived, which is a multiple of 19. And there's a bunch of other things in just that one chapter regarding Rashad's life. And we know that God controls life and death, right? So, there's a lot that God is pointing to with Rashad here, right?
I I I think I think people they they may see this, they think, "Oh, you're just picking patterns that are random." But in reality, if you believe that God knows all things and He does everything with intent and design, then you can no longer claim that it's random. God already knows what you're seeing and what you would see. Right? So, he he you need to understand that just God has counted the number of all things as we say, you know? Yeah. And so, these patterns are. There's there's so much, man. There's just so much. It's just it's overwhelming. You know, we we talk about verse 381. 381 is talking about the messenger of the covenant, right? What does it say? 381. God took a covenant from the prophets saying, "I will give you the scripture and wisdom. Afterwards, a messenger will come to confirm all existing scripture. You shall believe in him and support him." He said, "Do you agree with this and pledge to fulfill this covenant?" They said, "We agree." He said, "You have thus borne witness and I bear witness along with you." And this is the expression I said where it says, "A messenger will come to you confirming all existing scriptures." That's a multiple of 19. And you know, you add uh just like we're doing with the other ones, Rashad Khalifa plus the verse number, you get a multiple of 19 as well.
It's it's compelling.
Hey, guys, I I wanted to add something that Hassan just uh showed me right now, right? So, there are 10 chapters with the uh uh, you know, with with these mysterious initials, right? And from the first initial, which is in chapter 2:1, to chapter 19 of all verses, there are 1230 verses, which is the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa. And again, chapter 19 again. Very interesting, right? And then so so so here he is where did the math, right? And then chapter 19, as we talked about, has has the most initials. And if you add them up, uh, you know, Rashad lives 19,798, just like the number of initials in chapter 19. Yeah. And then and then we go to 1919, right? We go to 1919 and what is it? The the what is it? The gematrical value or or yeah, hold on. Yeah, the gematrical value is 1990 and the number of letters is 31. And he was he he was martyred on January 31st, 1990. But separate from that, let's just write the date of death, date of death, right? We got 31, hold on, it's blurry. You do that, it becomes blurry. Just remove that. Yeah. 31011990. That's 19 times 1230 times 1327. And 1230 is the uh initial verse is 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one.
The last one.
So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And the 1327th initial verse is the last verse of chapter 19. So, there's a lot hold on. It's code 19. Chapter 19 has the most initials of all of them. It has the number of initials corresponding to the number of days Rashad lived, which is a multiple of 19. And there's a bunch of other things in just that one chapter regarding Rashad's life. And we know that God controls life and death, right? So, there's a lot that God is pointing to with Rashad here, right?
I I I think I think people they they may see this, they think, "Oh, you're just picking patterns that are random." But in reality, if you believe that God knows all things and He does everything with intent and design, then you can no longer claim that it's random. God already knows what you're seeing and what you would see. Right? So, he he you need to understand that just God has counted the number of all things as we say, you know? Yeah. And so, these patterns are. There's there's so much, man. There's just so much. It's just it's overwhelming. You know, we we talk about verse 381. 381 is talking about the messenger of the covenant, right? What does it say? 381. God took a covenant from the prophets saying, "I will give you the scripture and wisdom. Afterwards, a messenger will come to confirm all existing scripture. You shall believe in him and support him." He said, "Do you agree with this and pledge to fulfill this covenant?" They said, "We agree." He said, "You have thus borne witness and I bear witness along with you." And this is the expression I said where it says, "A messenger will come to you confirming all existing scriptures." That's a multiple of 19. And you know, you add uh just like we're doing with the other ones, Rashad Khalifa plus the verse number, you get a multiple of 19 as well.
It's it's compelling.
Hey, guys, I I wanted to add something that Hassan just uh showed me right now, right? So, there are 10 chapters with the uh uh, you know, with with these mysterious initials, right? And from the first initial, which is in chapter 2:1, to chapter 19 of all verses, there are 1230 verses, which is the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa. And again, chapter 19 again. Very interesting, right? And then so so so here he is where did the math, right? And then chapter 19, as we talked about, has has the most initials. And if you add them up, uh, you know, Rashad lives 19,798, just like the number of initials in chapter 19. Yeah. And then and then we go to 1919, right? We go to 1919 and what is it? The the what is it? The gematrical value or or yeah, hold on. Yeah, the gematrical value is 1990 and the number of letters is 31. And he was he he was martyred on January 31st, 1990. But separate from that, let's just write the date of death, date of death, right? We got 31, hold on, it's blurry. You do that, it becomes blurry. Just remove that. Yeah. 31011990. That's 19 times 1230 times 1327. And 1230 is the uh initial verse is 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one.
The last one.
So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one.
The last one. [4m 14s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [4m 15s] The last one. [4m 15s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [4m 16s] The last one. [4m 16s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [4m 17s] The last one. [4m 17s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [4m 18s] The last one. [4m 18s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [4m 19s] The last one. [4m 19s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [4m 20s] The last one. [4m 20s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [4m 21s] The last one. [4m 21s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [4m 22s] The last one. [4m 22s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [4m 23s] The last one. [4m 23s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [4m 24s] The last one. [4m 24s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [4m 25s] The last one. [4m 25s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [4m 26s] The last one. [4m 26s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [4m 27s] The last one. [4m 27s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [4m 28s] The last one. [4m 28s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [4m 29s] The last one. [4m 29s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [4m 30s] The last one. [4m 30s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [4m 31s] The last one. [4m 31s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [4m 32s] The last one. [4m 32s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [4m 33s] The last one. [4m 33s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [4m 34s] The last one. [4m 34s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [4m 35s] The last one. [4m 35s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [4m 36s] The last one. [4m 36s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [4m 37s] The last one. [4m 37s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [4m 38s] The last one. [4m 38s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [4m 39s] The last one. [4m 39s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [4m 40s] The last one. [4m 40s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [4m 41s] The last one. [4m 41s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [4m 42s] The last one. [4m 42s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [4m 43s] The last one. [4m 43s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [4m 44s] The last one. [4m 44s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [4m 45s] The last one. [4m 45s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [4m 46s] The last one. [4m 46s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [4m 47s] The last one. [4m 47s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [4m 48s] The last one. [4m 48s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [4m 49s] The last one. [4m 49s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [4m 50s] The last one. [4m 50s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [4m 51s] The last one. [4m 51s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [4m 52s] The last one. [4m 52s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [4m 53s] The last one. [4m 53s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [4m 54s] The last one. [4m 54s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [4m 55s] The last one. [4m 55s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [4m 56s] The last one. [4m 56s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [4m 57s] The last one. [4m 57s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [4m 58s] The last one. [4m 58s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [4m 59s] The last one. [4m 59s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [5m 0s] The last one. [5m 0s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [5m 1s] The last one. [5m 1s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [5m 2s] The last one. [5m 2s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [5m 3s] The last one. [5m 3s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [5m 4s] The last one. [5m 4s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [5m 5s] The last one. [5m 5s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [5m 6s] The last one. [5m 6s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [5m 7s] The last one. [5m 7s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [5m 8s] The last one. [5m 8s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [5m 9s] The last one. [5m 9s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [5m 10s] The last one. [5m 10s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [5m 11s] The last one. [5m 11s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [5m 12s] The last one. [5m 12s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [5m 13s] The last one. [5m 13s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [5m 14s] The last one. [5m 14s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [5m 15s] The last one. [5m 15s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [5m 16s] The last one. [5m 16s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [5m 17s] The last one. [5m 17s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [5m 18s] The last one. [5m 18s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [5m 19s] The last one. [5m 19s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [5m 20s] The last one. [5m 20s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [5m 21s] The last one. [5m 21s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [5m 22s] The last one. [5m 22s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [5m 23s] The last one. [5m 23s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [5m 24s] The last one. [5m 24s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [5m 25s] The last one. [5m 25s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [5m 26s] The last one. [5m 26s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [5m 27s] The last one. [5m 27s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [5m 28s] The last one. [5m 28s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [5m 29s] The last one. [5m 29s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [5m 30s] The last one. [5m 30s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [5m 31s] The last one. [5m 31s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [5m 32s] The last one. [5m 32s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [5m 33s] The last one. [5m 33s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [5m 34s] The last one. [5m 34s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [5m 35s] The last one. [5m 35s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [5m 36s] The last one. [5m 36s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [5m 37s] The last one. [5m 37s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [5m 38s] The last one. [5m 38s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [5m 39s] The last one. [5m 39s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [5m 40s] The last one. [5m 40s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [5m 41s] The last one. [5m 41s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [5m 42s] The last one. [5m 42s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [5m 43s] The last one. [5m 43s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [5m 44s] The last one. [5m 44s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [5m 45s] The last one. [5m 45s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [5m 46s] The last one. [5m 46s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [5m 47s] The last one. [5m 47s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [5m 48s] The last one. [5m 48s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [5m 49s] The last one. [5m 49s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [5m 50s] The last one. [5m 50s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [5m 51s] The last one. [5m 51s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [5m 52s] The last one. [5m 52s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [5m 53s] The last one. [5m 53s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [5m 54s] The last one. [5m 54s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [5m 55s] The last one. [5m 55s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [5m 56s] The last one. [5m 56s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [5m 57s] The last one. [5m 57s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [5m 58s] The last one. [5m 58s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [5m 59s] The last one. [5m 59s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [6m 0s] The last one. [6m 0s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [6m 1s] The last one. [6m 1s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [6m 2s] The last one. [6m 2s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [6m 3s] The last one. [6m 3s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [6m 4s] The last one. [6m 4s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [6m 5s] The last one. [6m 5s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [6m 6s] The last one. [6m 6s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [6m 7s] The last one. [6m 7s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [6m 8s] The last one. [6m 8s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [6m 9s] The last one. [6m 9s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [6m 10s] The last one. [6m 10s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [6m 11s] The last one. [6m 11s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [6m 12s] The last one. [6m 12s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [6m 13s] The last one. [6m 13s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [6m 14s] The last one. [6m 14s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [6m 15s] The last one. [6m 15s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [6m 16s] The last one. [6m 16s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [6m 17s] The last one. [6m 17s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [6m 18s] The last one. [6m 18s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [6m 19s] The last one. [6m 19s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [6m 20s] The last one. [6m 20s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [6m 21s] The last one. [6m 21s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [6m 22s] The last one. [6m 22s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [6m 23s] The last one. [6m 23s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [6m 24s] The last one. [6m 24s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [6m 25s] The last one. [6m 25s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [6m 26s] The last one. [6m 26s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [6m 27s] The last one. [6m 27s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [6m 28s] The last one. [6m 28s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [6m 29s] The last one. [6m 29s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [6m 30s] The last one. [6m 30s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [6m 31s] The last one. [6m 31s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [6m 32s] The last one. [6m 32s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [6m 33s] The last one. [6m 33s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [6m 34s] The last one. [6m 34s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [6m 35s] The last one. [6m 35s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [6m 36s] The last one. [6m 36s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [6m 37s] The last one. [6m 37s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa times the multiplier, right? And the 1230th initial verse is is verse 19:1. And get this, 1327 initial verse is 1998. The last the last one. [6m 38s] The last one. [6m 38s] So, and 1230 is is is not like an a random number. It's the gematrical value of Rashad Khalifa, right? So, if if you get the multiple of of, you know, the 31st of January 1990, it's 19 times the